cualquier jugador que se respete ha
tratado al menos una vez de llegar hasta
los límites de su juego favorito y ver
que se esconde más allá
ya sea para encontrarte con un
monstruote que te hará pedazos y te
acercas demasiado o para conocer
dinosaurios robóticos que también te
harán pedazos y te acercas demasiado
Ojalá hubiera videojuegos infinitos
créeme si hubiera podido quedarme toda
la vida criando vacas y golpeando gente
en 2 lo hubiera hecho sin dudarlo un
segundo pero no se puede los juegos no
pueden tener mapas infinitos porque
necesitaríamos una PC con la energía de
14 soles para eso es por eso que los
desarrolladores deben colocar límites en
sus mapas la mayoría de veces siendo
algo Bastante normal como una simple
pared invisible pero otras veces le
ponen más huevos y agregan maneras más
divertidas y locas de mantenerte a raya
y hoy te voy a mostrar 15 de las maneras
más creativas en que los juegos evitan
que te salgas del mapa
[Música]
el videojuego de Mad Max tiene una zona
que se llama el gran vacío algo que
existe tanto en el juego como en las
películas esta zona era una parte del
mundo llena de vida pero debido al
desmadre nuclear y ecológico que
nosotros los humanos armamos a lo
[__] Ahora solo es un infinito
desierto con un clima mortal Esto fue
algo que los desarrolladores
aprovecharon Pues si tratas de salir del
mapa llegarás al gran vacío y lo único
que te recibirá ahí es una tormenta de
arena que te matará lentamente
el mundo decías es bastante amplio pero
cuando navegas muy lejos el mar y hasta
el cielo lentamente comenzarán a
advertirte que no seas [__] y te
regreses Pues empezarán a teñirse de
rojo pero si continúas tu barco se
destruirá por sí solo y morirás ahogado
en GTA 5 hicieron algo más simple pero
bastante creativo pues no importa en qué
vehículo intente salir del mapa después
de unos kilómetros el vehículo se dañará
y se hundirá en el mar y un tiburón te
mandará directo con San Pedro Tan pronto
toques el agua
de 2001 si tratas de salir del mapa en
una carrera normal solamente
reaparecerás de nuevo
pero si juegas en el modo libre y te
alejas demasiado esta vez nadie
intentará detenerte porque un tentáculo
gigante te hará pedazos antes de que
llegues muy lejos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es un juego de supervivencia y
exploración con un mapa bastante grande
aquí en lugar de molestarse agregando
algún límite para su mapa aprovechando
la cultura nórdica en la que se ambienta
el juego crearon el mapa de manera de
que si te alejas lo suficiente llegarás
al fin del mundo
no literalmente te caes por el borde del
mundo y te mueres
[Música]
según la trama de Arkham City Batman
está Atrapado en una de las prisiones
más grandes del mundo Así que tiene
sentido que cuando trates de volar sobre
los muros los guardias intenten
acribillarte y te disparan un cartucho
entero pensando que eres un criminal que
trata de escapar
Sport de 2008 es un juego de
supervivencia en el cual inicias como
una bolita ojona con patas luchando por
sobrevivir pero vas evolucionando con el
pasar del tiempo el mapa del juego está
rodeado de agua y aunque tu personaje
puede nadar no es una buena idea pues
sin nada es muy lejos un monstruo marino
te recordará que el agua no siempre es
buena
a pesar de que Slender de rival no es un
juego con mucho presupuesto como otros y
que tenía bastantes problemas técnicos
les sobraba creatividad y como sabían
que tarde o temprano algún jugador iba a
salirse del mapa usando algún bug
hicieron que cuando el juego detectara
que estás fuera del mapa Slenderman te
atrapará instantáneamente no sin antes
decirte ni siquiera un error en este
juego te salvará de mí perro
No [__] casi me cago del susto project
ID es un juego que tiene algo que se
llama mapa generado proceduralmente es
decir que el mapa se va creando a medida
que avanzas es un mapa infinito pues
pero en ciertas misiones por
limitaciones técnicas si tuvieron que
poner un límite y su idea fue colocar un
campo minado en los límites del juego
Así que si andabas de curioso un mal
paso y
Aunque a día de hoy Resident Evil esté
lleno de vampiras en su alonas y hombres
lobo en 4k en 1996 cuando salió el
Resident Evil original habían muchas
limitaciones técnicas pero como sabían
que íbamos a tratar de salir de la
mansión para ver que había por ahí
añadieron una pequeña escena en donde
unos perros zombies nos atacarán si nos
acercamos a la puerta
esto es mucho peor en el remake en donde
el perro incluso entra a la mansión y
Tendremos que pelear con él por mirones
en el juego de Padre de familia de 2001
no querían esforzarse mucho así que
pusieron una pared invisible bastante
común pero como lo hicieron algo
Bastante creativo un mimo
en serio Sam 3 te encontrará situado en
un mapa rodeado por un enorme desierto
si por algún motivo que ni tú entiendes
decides que quieres explorar el desierto
fuera del área permitida un gusano te
comenzará a perseguirte hasta matarte en
Horizon West Ocurre algo similar Pues si
tratas de salirte del mapa nadando unos
hipopótamos robóticos gigantes de
atacarán hasta que te regreses o te
mueras lo que pase primero
[Música]
recuerdas que en la serie de Bob Esponja
solía salir de vez en cuando está manota
hiperrealista llamada Hans que ayudaba a
boba a hacer sus idioteces bueno en el
juego de Bob Esponja de 2021 se hizo una
gran referencia a esto pues cada vez que
intentabas explorar los límites del
juego la mano de hámster estruja muy
amablemente y te devuelve a donde
deberías estar
subnáutica tiene un mapa enorme Así que
no será sencillo escapar Pero si te
alejas lo suficiente o te sumerges a lo
más profundo entrarás a una zona
conocida como la zona muerta una zona
totalmente oscura y abandonada por Dios
en la que te estará esperando el
leviatán fantasma la segunda criatura
más grande y peligrosa del juego que se
encargará de proteger los límites del
mapa y hacerte [__] para castigar tu
curiosidad
como has visto la mayoría de juegos si
no es que todos ponen un gran esfuerzo
en no dejarte salir del mapa pero no
ubisoft se cansaron de ti y tus [__]
Por lo que en Far Cry 6 ni siquiera se
esforzarán en mantenerte dentro del mapa
quiere salir lárgate pero si lo haces
activarás un final secreto por lo que el
juego terminará de inmediato y te
mostrará una cinemática en donde el país
que suponía que debía salvar se va al
[__] mientras tú te relajas en una
playa lejos de las balas y esas cosas
a pesar de la tragedia la empresa
promete que su nuevo parque turístico
secreto abrirá pronto al público
en otras noticias terminó la guerra en
yara el presidente Antón Castillo
anunció que Clara García la líder del
grupo terrorista libertad fue asesinada
por sus fuerzas especiales
Oye estoy confundido es un final triste
o un final feliz Es un final y basta hay
muchos otros juegos con banderas muy
locas de mantenerte dentro del mapa Pero
estas son las más interesantes que pude
encontrar Aunque si conoces alguna otra
que merezca un lugar en este vídeo ya
sabes que hacer como siempre gracias a
todos por ver el video no se olviden de
seguirme en mis suculentas redes
sociales y Apoyar el canal por ahora Eso
es todo de mi parte hasta la próxima
[Música]